as we approach the end let us descend
into the meme further and further uh Ben
you're in a monogamous marriage uh and
Destiny you've been mostly in an open
marriage until recently how foundational
is marriage monogamous marriage to to
the United States of America can open
marriages work are they harmful to
society um Ben marriages are the single
most important thing that people can do
in the United States because the things
within your control are easier to
control than the things outside your
control people tend to think about big
political change obviously about things
they can do to change the entire system
but the reality is the thing that you
can do that best change of society is to
get married and have kids and raise your
kids responsibly that is the single best
thing that you can do can an open
marriage work I mean I think that it
depends on your definition of work so in
my version of work the answer is no
because what you actually need in order
to facilitate the healthy growing of a
child it's a father and mother who are
committed to each other all idea all
ideas about there being no emotional
comp opponent to sexual activity are
completely specious uh that it's is trer
for men than it is for women but it's
not true for either uh the the idea of a
full a full commitment to a human being
with whom you genetically create
children which is typically how we've
done it throughout human existence is in
fact the fundamental basis for any
functional civilization it allows for
the transmission of culture and values
it allows for the transmission of
beliefs and
responsibility and it is it gives the
great lie to both the communitarian lie
and the and the atomistic individualist
LIE the communitarian LIE is that you
belong to the giant community of man
which is not true because you have a
family uh and your Allegiance should be
and is naturally to the members of your
family first that's how we learn and
then we expound that out uh and it also
is a lie to the notion that we are all
atomistic individuals with no
responsibilities we are born into a
world of responsibilities everyone is
born into a world of responsibilities
and rules and roles and those are good
and if we do not actually socialize our
children that way there will be number
one no children number one there will be
no healthy CH number two there will be
no healthy children number three there
will be not the foundation for either
social fabric which is the real glue
that holds together Society or for a
functional government so you yes yes
monogamous marriage I'm a fan 15 years
married four kids yes Destiny what do
you think um I think that when we talk
about like relationships or marriage I
think something that's really important
is we have to talk about whether or not
children are being discussed or not um
because I think once you introduce the
child aspect I think the style or the
type of relationship that you do is
going to become way more important than
whatever exists prior to that um like I
would agree for instance for in terms of
what Ben is saying that um there's
probably going to be some structure that
is ideal for the uh care and the raising
of a child um I think that having a
child gives you a much bigger Buy in to
society because now all of a sudden you
care about a lot of things that you
might not have before because not only
do you exist in society you can't just
run uh now you've got a child that
exists there and you've got to ensure
that everything functions smoothly not
just for you but for that child as well
well um and arguably although we're
getting into weird places I guess in the
world now like children are the primary
conduit through for like where you
transmit like cultural values and
everything um the one kind of weird
thing that we're coming up against that
we have been coming up against um now
for for some number of decades and we'll
continue to is as societies progress
seems like people are having less
children and I actually don't know 100%
what the answer is to that question um
I'm sure you do yeah I mean an imple
answer that works that we know we can
get everybody on board with um it seems
like for a large part of human history
um having children and it still is
having children is awesome and children
are cool and children are magical and
miraculous and all of this but you
didn't really have much competing for
your attention to have a child right
when you hit a certain age and you
started working um especially if you
were a woman I mean child birth is kind
of the next step and then having a
family raising your children and then
doing that is kind of The Next Step
nowadays especially with women being
able to work especially women having
access to birth control there's a lot
available in the world world that's
competing for the interest of people
that could otherwise be having children
such that we've almost flipped it such
that has been brought up earlier like
wealthy people tend to have less
children then not wealthy people um or
unless you're part of particular
religious communities that push child
birth a lot I don't know if I would say
there exists a a moral imperative on an
individual to have children I think that
there's a lot of interesting arguments
down that path I don't know if we're
quite at the point yet where we need to
say like oh my God we're running out of
people we need to have more kids um I
don't think we're quite there yet but we
are seeing you know weird demographic
trends that are having big impacts on
how countries are playing out for
instance the fact that we have a
disproportionately huge aging population
that needs to be taken care of with
medical expenses and everything that
vote in different ways than our younger
population and that when they die off
like the way that Society is going to
look is going to be a lot different um
yeah I I don't I don't actually have a
I'm not entirely sure what the future's
going to look like in terms of pushing
people to have kids when every single
industrialized country as they become
more industrialized have fewer and fewer
and fewer children rapid fire questions
by the answer my my answer was go to
religion yeah I F yeah well we could
talk about religion but that's not rapid
fire at
all